Let's bring up H O D. Is that the
>> uh Hello. Thank you, God Logic, for
introducing me.
>> So, uh hopefully we're going to have a
respectful and great conversation today.
So, could one of you guys explain to me
what the Islamic dilemma is?
>> Sure.
>> Yep. I can do it real quick. That's all
good. Go
>> ahead. The Islamic dilemma is the idea
that within Islam and particularly in
the Quran itself, the Quran confirms the
scriptures that the Jews and the
Christians had both uh when they came
down to the respective prophets, but
also in Muhammad's time, the Quran
confirms them. It says they're inspired,
preserved, and authoritative. And yet
that same Quran also contradicts major
themes and narratives found in those
same scriptures. Hence, the Quran is
incoherent. It's inconsistent and the
author seems not to be aware of what
those previous scriptures were and yet
he affirms them anyway. And this would
show that the author of the Quran is not
divine because he's ignorant of what the
previous scriptures contained. There's a
very brief summary of the Islamic
dilemma.
>> Okay. Okay. Thank you for explaining to
me.
>> Let me just add that what what it the
dilemma you those two horns of the
dilemma. If the Bible has been
corrupted, Islam is false. If the Bible
has been preserved, Islam is false. So
that's why it's a dilemma because no
matter which horn you take, you end up
saying Islam is false. If the Bible has
not been corrupted, then we can go to
the Bible, we can judge by it as surah
547 says, surah 568, we can judge by it
and we can say, hey, we can judge Islam
as false. But if the Bible has been
corrupted, then the Quran is confirming
corrupted scriptures. So e either way,
Islam is false. Those are the two horns
if that helps to add some context. So
what if I say that it's a false dilemma
because the Quran never affirms the
current corrupted versions of the Bible
but only the original revelations given
to Moses, Jesus and others.
>> I would show you that out of the 18 mlic
verses, there are six of them that
explicitly mention the scriptures held
by the people of the book that being the
Christians and the Jews at the time of
Muhammad in the 7th century.
>> Can you tell me the verses?
>> Yes.
>> 87 is one. So we're seven.
>> Let's go. Let's go slowly, please.
>> Sure. So let's go with 289 is one.
>> Okay. 289. Okay.
>> 291.
>> 447.
>> Yeah,
>> I believe 41 as well. 241.
>> Well, let's start with uh let's slowly
start with 289 and 291. So, from my
understanding, those verses show that
when the book came to them confirming
what they already knew, they rejected it
out of arrogance. But um but but this
doesn't mean the Quran affirms corrupted
versions they had.
>> No, it says confirming what was with
them. Mhm.
>> So what was the cruising the Yeah,
that's in the Arabic transliteration
confirming what was with them. And
that's in 289.
>> Could I explain the phrase? So the
phrase what was with them refers to the
remnants of the original revelation.
>> Where does where does he say he's
referring to remnants?
>> The Quran says in surah 279 who to those
who write the book with their own hands.
>> Okay. So hang on hang just just to just
clarify. If I write a book with my own
hands, that means that uh that all other
books have been corrupt. What? What are
you talking about? If I write a book
with my hand right now, matter of fact,
let's say let's suppose I write a book
right now and I call it and I say this
is the matter of fact, let's say I just
write something right now and I say this
is the Quran. Jesus is Lord. Have I
corrupted the Quran? Is the Quran
corrupted?
>> Uh if you false if you false if you
falsely claim uh you written is divine
revelation and mix it with the original,
you corrupted the scripture.
>> Okay. So I've corrupted the Quran. You
you would agree that now you you just
agreed that the Quran has been
corrupted.
>> No, if
>> Yeah. I I just said that this is the
Quran and this
>> Yeah, it's a piece of paper. I can see.
>> Yeah, I know. So, uh I just said that
this is the Quran.
>> Yeah, but that's not the Quran. The
Quran is pervers is preserved by mass.
>> That's our point.
>> Any false edition you make is instantly
rejected.
>> Yeah, you're saying you're saying that
279, which by the way is the the only
verse in the Quran you can even point to
that even sounds like it's talking about
changing a book. As long as you don't
read the entire context. As long as you
don't read what comes before and read
what comes after.
>> I'm studying you. I could explain.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um that's the only that's
the only verse that even sounds like
it's talking about a book. And what does
it say? Woe to those who write the book
with their own hands and then say this
is from Allah. So if you're saying that
someone doing that, someone writing
something and saying this is from Allah
means that the book all over the planet
has been corrupted. One, we think that's
that sounds completely insane to us. And
to illustrate that, I say, okay, if I
write something and I say this is from
Allah, which is what the that's what
that verse is condemning, writing
something and saying this is from Allah.
Now, guess what? You can condemn that.
So, you could condemn me for saying that
I wrote something and said this the
Quran, you could condemn me for that,
which is what the Quran is saying. But
if you say, "Therefore, I did this. I
wrote something and said it's the book.
Therefore, the book has been corrupted."
If you're saying that, then you're
forced to say that the Quran has been
corrupted because I just did exactly
what the Quran says. Could you please
explain 279 for me?
>> He just did.
>> Yeah, I just went the whole explanation
for
>> Yeah. two surah surah 2 Surah 2 vers79.
Here here's uh here's the big problem.
You can go to a bunch of different
Muslim commentaries and get a bunch of
different Muslim explanations as to what
that is about. Um you have you have
Muslim commentaries that say this is
about someone writing something in
addition to the Torah and passing it off
as if it's the Torah. So this would be
something like the Talmud. writing
commentaries on something, but you're
treating those commentaries as if
they're from uh as if they're the Torah.
So, you have those kinds of
commentaries. You'll have the only ones
that talk about textual like changing
the text say that um either that some
Jews wrote a false prophecy about the
coming prophet to throw people off the
track and actually like like put that in
the Torah or they wrote something just
down on paper like this and said, "Um,
hey guys, this is this is what the Torah
says. This is what the Torah says about
the prophet and you can see it doesn't
line up with Muhammad. So you have that
sort of criticism. Then you have other
things that other things that say like
that uh Jews were writing blessings and
selling them like they're giving Jewish
blessings and selling them and things
like that and that's why it mean that's
why it says a small price. But that's
kind of an issue. None of your
commentators can agree on what this is
even talking about and a and most of the
interpretations wouldn't involve
corrupting the actual text. And so we
would be inclined to say if the verses
before it, if the verses before it say
that Allah is confirming what they have
and just six verses later Allah says if
you only believe in parts and not all of
it I'll send you to hell. And then you
have all these other verses after it
where he says he's confirming what you
have. He's confirming what you have.
He's confirming what you have. We would
go with an interpretation that doesn't
contradict everything else Allah says in
his entire book. So we'd give an
interpretation that is consistent.
Whereas, so we, in other words, we would
go to the clear verses. And if we have
an ambiguous verse, what does this mean?
Is this talking about actual changing a
copy of the Torah? Is it talking about
writing another book in addition to the
Torah? What is this talking about?
Muslim commentators can't even agree.
So, we say, "Okay, that verse is
ambiguous. Let's go with the clear
verses and use those to interpret the
unclear verse." That's standard. Whether
you're talking about the Bible, the
Quran, that's a fundamental rule of
interpreting scriptures. Don't throw out
the clear for the sake of the unclear.
you use the clear, go with the clear and
use those to interpret unclear verses.
So when we're going to this, all the
clear verses are in our favor. Muslims
only point to the most a a tremendously
ambiguous verse and they give it an
interpretation that doesn't make sense
of the rest of the chapter, let alone
the rest of the book. And we just think
that's a very sloppy methodology.
>> Okay. So, uh I I have a response, but
but the clear verses like 275, uh 513,
uh another
>> none of none of those none of those. You
just pointed out the most ambiguous
verses in the Quran.
>> Interrupt me. It's subjective. You're
saying ambiguous doesn't mean it's
ambiguous, but it's ambiguous. Ambiguous
means it's open to multiple
interpretations.
279 is a for a fact is open to multiple
interpretations cuz we can give you 10
different interpretations just from your
own commentators. Same thing with 275.
Same thing with 5 513. The problem is
it's not clear if it's you could
interpret it as changing a text, but you
could also interpret it as people just
misrepresenting and distorting it what
they teach, which is what 378 teaches.
So that that's what we're saying. You
guys go to the to the most ambiguous
verses. You insert the meaning you want,
which is not what it says. And by doing
so, you contradict all of the clear
verses which affirm the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of our text.
>> David, David, could I finish my without
you interrupting? All right. So, like I
said, we have 513, 541 that directly say
some Jews distorted the words of Allah.
So, using verses to interpret 279
actually proves textual corruption.
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. How How
are you not getting this? You just said
it says they distort it. Yes. How? 378
tells you how they distort it. They
distort it with their speech. Dude, the
the actual condemnation of Jews and
Christians in your scriptures is not
that we change our scriptures. It's that
we don't follow our scriptures. It's
that we distort the meaning. We
misinterpret. We misrepresent. We even
lie about our scriptures. It's never
we've corrupted our scriptures. And so
when you go to verses and say, "Aha,
here it says they distort the
scriptures." Yes, it does say that. And
378 tells you how. And if you're saying,
"No, when it says distort," I'm just
going to say, even though you could
interpret it either way, I'm going to
say it means changing the text. Even
though Allah never once says we're
changing the text and everything he says
only makes sense if he's talking about
uncorrupted text that we have. So
>> it's quite funny. You did you know 513?
You've skipped 513. Do you know what 53?
>> You mentioned 513. I mentioned 513.
>> What does it say? It says
so they distort the words.
>> Excuse me. Do you know what
he is?
>> Yes. I was about to give the
translation.
>> Okay. Changing changing the words from
their places.
>> No mean that means they
don't trust you. I trust I am Abz.
That's what I trust.
>> Do you know Arab or not?
>> I I am a Moroccan. So I know Arabic.
>> You're Moroccan. Okay. Do you know what
Ma means?
>> I know what mad means.
>> Yeah. What does it mean? Uh it means uh
the the the place or position.
>> Thank you. So now you trust me because
you agree with me. So they change the
words from their places, does that mean
the places are known or not known?
>> No. In in this context,
>> dude, I'm asking you a question. Answer
me. If I change something from if I
change a cup from its place, does that
mean it place?
>> It was already in its place.
>> Yes. The place were not. That means it
has to be with the mouth. That's why in
another place in the Quran, it says
It says that in another place. No, no,
no.
>> It does say don't say no. It's from the
Quran. It say I don't trust you. I
trust. What does
>> Ab doesn't say what you're saying
though. Ab says what we're saying.
>> Do you want me to pause? Do you want us
to
>> I didn't even finish what I wanted to
say for you to say.
>> Put it on the screen. No, no, no. Do you
want us to put Abbas on the screen?
>> I could I could give you a source.
>> Okay. So, you're saying that you have a
quote from Abbas on chapter 5 verse 13.
>> Let's go. Where is
>> Is that what you're claiming? Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. Great. So, what's the
commentary?
>> So, wait. Let me pull it up here.
>> Okay. So, you don't have it?
>> No, I'm currently pulling it up.
>> Okay. So, you don't have it. I asked you
if you had it. You don't have it. So,
you can look it up if it exists. Let us
know where you're going to go to.
>> The state of Ibn Abbas. Yeah.
>> What's up? What? There's no tough state
of Abbas. What's Which commentary are
you going to
>> Which commentary is Abbas in that you're
going to?
>> You know, you know,
>> I want to because I I don't think he
knows what he's talking about. Maybe you
sound You sound young. It's I know
you're a little you're a little excited.
Maybe you're getting
>> I'm not excited at all.
>> Okay, just just Okay, just take take a
second. So, you think that Nabbas
comments on 513? Which commentary quotes
Abbas on 513 and he says what you're
saying?
>> Oh, wait. I'm in also you please like
>> just give me one second.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So, you said something without
knowing and now you're going to check if
it's there.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no. I I seen it. You
said I trustbas I don't trust you. You
said you said I trust Ibas. I don't
trust you. So we want to see what
Innabas said on chapter 5 verse3.
>> That's going to take a lot of time.
>> So wait, why did you say you trust
Abbas? What? Okay, if you don't have it
in front of you, what does your memory
tell you that Abbas said about 513? Just
give us a rough paraphrase of what you
think he said. So from memory Iban Abbas
explained that they distort the words
from their places as changing both the
wording and the meaning
>> which is why classical
and also mention both uh the the textual
and interpretive corruption
>> textual if I change something's meaning
when I'm talking about it that's not
textual
>> so we'll show you what Abbas said. Okay.
Uh, so if you want to pull up your
commentary, you can go to for chapter,
sorry, not go to
for chapter 3:78. Okay, 3 verse 78. And
we'll show you what exactly did Abbas
say. Okay, so 3 verse 78.
>> We can put it on the screen if you want.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It said I don't even It says
that some like Jews changed the word.
>> No, no, no. You saidnabbass. You said I
don't trust you. I trustbas. So what
we're going to do now, I want to put it
on the screen.
>> Yeah, we'll show you what word for word
whatnas actually says.
>> According to
you see this word here?
>> Wait, it's not on the screen yet. Hold
on.
>> Okay, let's
>> Avery, you want to put that up on the
screen for giant doc?
>> Hold up.
>> One second. What? Okay, there you go.
>> There you go. You see this word here
now?
>> Scroll down. Let's go down.
>> Oops. Okay. We'll just scroll up to show
that it's you see that here in there.
See? Okay.
>> Now go Now we're going to go to Abbass.
Now you said you trust Iban Abbas.
Great. Good. Let's see what Abbas said.
>> They distort where and they add
and no one from the creation of Allah.
removes
a wording from the book of any books of
Allah. You see that?
>> Yes. What does it mean?
They distort it. What does it mean?
These two dots meaning
they give it a meaning different to its
meaning.
>> In other words, they misinterpret it.
They don't change the actual text or the
actual words. They misinterpret it. So
that's what Abbas actually said.
>> You should know Elisa. You're a
Moroccan, but you should know.
>> No, I know. I know.
>> Yeah. Means no. No one.
>> No one can change the wording
>> from a from a book from the books of
Allah. What's wrong with that?
>> No. So, no, there's nothing wrong with
it. The point is he tells you what does
what does it mean to corrupt? What he
tells you it means what corrupting means
is to misinterpret.
That's what it means. It doesn't mean
like like how David was showing you how
he has a piece of paper and then someone
else take that piece of paper and they
change the words. No, it's taking that
piece of paper that David has and
someone misinterprets it. They don't
change the words, they misinterpret the
words. So that's what Abbas said. He
said that it's not possible to do the
type of corruption that you're talking
about. The only corruption that's
possible is uh for example like we're
all talking about the Quran right now
and one of us is misinterpreting the
Quran, right? We can't both be right.
One of us is misinterpreting the Quran.
But you would you wouldn't say therefore
the Quran is corrupt, right? Because
some of one of us is misinterpreting it.
Correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But the literally says
removes the wording from the book of
Allah.
It says no one can read.
>> No one can.
>> Yeah. Yes. But but keep reading on cuz
he explains what does it mean to
corrupt.
>> You see these two dots here.
>> What is What is
>> and
>> what is? Yeah.
>> What does do with sentences?
>> Yeah. But you have to keep reading.
>> Yeah, we have to keep reading. So I can
I can add in my interpretation
something.
>> So what it doesn't mean I put it in the
book. How do we know? Because it goes on
because it says no one from Allah's
creation can change some can can remove
something in the book of Allah
>> from those books. And it goes on to say
but what do they do? They corrupt
according to the interpretation. They
misinterpret it.
>> And that's what it means to change the
words from their places.
It means the places are known but when
they come to interpret it to the people
means to interpret to the people they
change the things from their places when
I like when they talk to them because no
one no one can remove anything from the
book of Allah.
>> Do you guys have a degree in Arabic?
>> You don't need a degree. This is basic
Arabic
>> because you
hold Wait. So you tell us what does the
Arabic mean? You tell us what does it
mean.
>> Okay. So this is what it's saying.
>> Okay. Yeah. No one can remove a word
from the books of Allah. Meaning, no one
can erase Allah's original revelation
from his
>> That's a contradiction. That's a contra
>> That's a contradiction. You're saying
that it can move from the original
words, but I mean like you're saying
that the original was distorted and
corrupted. So which is it? That's you're
contradicting yourself. The originals
were corrupted. Now you're saying they
can't move from the original. Yes, it
is.
>> Uh Allah's preserved record in the Als
can be translated
wait
earthly copies.
>> Uh, does it say here? Can you show me
where it says?
>> I'm talking about his arguments.
>> Okay. But but you you just said you just
asked if we have degrees in Arabic. So
that means that you were saying
something that's incorrect according to
the Arabic. So go to the Arabic. I don't
know what you were doing earlier, but
you weren't translating. Translate what
it says for the people so that everyone
can know what it means.
>> Yeah, let's go
>> with your with your degree in Arabic or
whatever you have.
>> Yeah, let's go word by word. I don't
have a degree in Arabic. I'm actually a
humble man.
>> Okay. So, so you don't know the Arabic.
So, how are you going to tell us that
we're wrong?
>> Excuse me. Do you go to a Chinese person
and ask them, "Do you have a Chinese?"
>> Let me answer.
>> No. Do you go to a Chinese person and
ask them, "Do you have a Chinese
degree?"
>> You need a degree in
>> this is not complicated. Arabic is not
English.
>> This is not This is not complicated
Arabic. What do you What is the
alternative meaning?
>> Okay. Tell me what which word is
complicated and we'll go we'll go. said
you said to translate it. Let me
translate.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> But I thought you h I thought I thought
you were too humble to translate. So
which one is it?
>> So it it it is reported from even at
best that they distort and change an ad,
but no one can remove a single word.
>> No, you already messed up. You already
messed up. You said you already you
already missed us.
>> Yeah. Which what is this?
>> What is you know how we
>> Why did you Why did you skip over that?
>> Yeah, we're not going to let could be no
one.
>> Oh, no. This is no one. There's no one.
>> Yeah. What's
>> But
you know what? You know what? We'll make
it easy for you cuz you
>> We know. We know. Wait. An animal can an
animal can change. We know that it's
talking about humans, but no one does
one.
>> Wait. So, no. So, are you are you agree
that you agree that no human can change
the word of Allah?
>> Oh my god. Can I please like finish my
translation?
>> Let's go, man. Can can humans change the
words of Allah or not? I I believe yes
humans can and did change the words are
earthly copies but no one can alter what
Allah has preserved in the
wrong
>> so if Abbas is wrong
>> cuz you remember you said earlier you
trust Abbas you trustbas right
>> he is saying Allah's words are preserved
with him
>> he he doesn't say with one second where
does it say with him
>> no not not in this but you're only
humble I have to go by this cuz this if
>> it's the corrupted words of Ibn Abbas
even
really quick really quick. So is Ibn
Abbas correct here? Uh ho that when he
says that none can remove the words of
Allah from his books. Is he wrong about
that or is he is he right about that?
>> He's correct. No one can remove Allah's
words from his preserved record. Um
>> and then when he says I got you. So then
when he says they alter and distort
their apparent meanings. So does Abbas
say that they distort the text or does
he say that they distort the meaning?
>> Abbas says they distort both the wording
and the meaning.
>> All right. Where does Abbas say that
they distort the text?
>> So if you if you check the again they
remove
>> we're looking at it's in English now.
That should be helpful.
>> Where does he say they distort the text
my brother? Because we gota we got to be
honest with what's in front of us,
right?
>> Yeah. They remove a wording from the
book of Allah can remove the words of
Allah from his books.
>> They can or can't.
>> None among Allah's uh creation can
remove the words of Allah from his
books.
>> So is it possible or not?
>> So the words can't be changed. The words
can't be changed. Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> So Abas says the words cannot be changed
but they can be distorted in their
meaning. Right.
>> Yes. They they could. So according to
Ibn Abbas, the text is perfectly
preserved. It's unchangeable, but people
can misunderstand
and misrepresent what the text says.
Right.
>> Uh okay, Mr. Socrates. Yes. But that
only applies to Allah's preserved
record, not the physical record.
>> Does it say preserved record or does it
say his books?
>> No, I'm not I'm not going even at best
wording for wording. I'm not going to
take a whole sentence and make a
conclusion out of it. That's That's
>> You're the one who appealed to Abbas.
>> Yeah. Who said? Was it us or you?
>> Why do we bring him Abbas up? Cuz you
brought him up.
>> Yeah, we're quoting Allah. You went to
Abbas.
>> Yeah, because his books in often means
the original revelation as preserved by
Allah. So, it's not that copy.
>> Where does it say that? No, this is a
clear conception about what books his
books in means often means. Sorry.
>> What's your name, bro? Cuz I don't want
to call you ho D or you know what can I
call you, man? You could call me D.
>> D. All right, sounds good. So So D,
listen. We have to be for us to
progress, we have to be honest with with
the text, man. Can can we at least agree
that with the text in front of us, whatn
Abbas says in front of us that he says
that the text itself cannot be changed.
>> Yeah, but what does the words of Allah
mean here?
>> What does the word of Allah means here
from his books? What does his books
mean?
>> Do you want to read on? that will help
with that. Another uh scholar, you want
to say see what he wrote? You want to
read word for word
>> because he tells you the books right
here.
>> The Torah and the Inil remain as Allah
revealed them and no letter in them was
removed. However,
>> this has nothing to do with the previous
>> Let's finish reading it.
>> The next sentence has nothing to do with
so so Iban Kadir had no idea what he was
doing. He was just putting random
sentences together.
>> However,
>> he was giving multiple opinions. Smart
man.
>> Shall we shall we shall we look at this
opinion then? The people misguide others
by false interpretation and addition
relying on the books they wrote
themselves.
>> Oh, that sounds like exactly how David
explained 279. Hm.
>> Wait. So, wait, hold on a second really
quick. So, does that so quoting David
was so Abu car reported a Boston and
then Wob David Wunabi said that okay so
that that is David Wood's words. David,
you said
>> very funny man.
>> You said that exactly.
>> Yeah. I built the time machine. I mean,
I went back and I inserted all these
words into.
>> So, it looks like
>> Yeah, but 279 specifically condemns
writing books and claiming they're from
Allah, which is exactly what happened.
>> That's true.
>> Right. Right. Right. Right. Look, look
what it says right there. Relying on
books they wrote from them, they wrote
themselves. If you And by the way,
little little side note, dude, here's
here's the tremendous irony, right? So,
people were writing stuff and people
have done this. You write commentaries
and so on, but you treat then you treat
your commentaries as if they're the word
of God and as as if the commentaries are
authoritative. The Quran condemns that.
You're using extra you're writing
something yourself and then acting like
that's the word of God. The Quran
condemns that. What did you do when we
went to your God? You said, "Oh, and
Abas and if you go to the if you go to
his and wait a minute. Well, either
Allah says it. either Allah says it, in
which case you should be able to show us
Allah saying it, or you're going outside
of what Allah says to another book and
saying, "Here, this is what Allah says."
In which case, you're quoting imm.
The very verse you're quoting condemns
you as a hypocrite. And
>> why are you lying, man? That's not what
the Quran says. The Quran condemns those
who distort or hide the actual words of
Allah. How can they hide? Wait, how can
they hide them? How can they How can
they hide the words if they're not
there?
>> What do you mean?
>> You said that people hide the words of
Allah.
>> If I hide the If I hide the word of
Allah, then I have to have the word of
Allah that I'm hiding, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Not the problem. If you want to say, if
you want to say, "Aha, the Quran accuses
the Jews of hiding what their book
wrote. The Quran accuses the Christians
of hiding what their book wrote." Okay,
that means they they still have the
reliable book and they're hiding it. You
can't hide something you don't have,
>> bro. They can only hide the words if
they're present in their scriptures.
>> Yeah, exactly what you did.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, they're present then.
So, they're present. You just made
>> He just said that they can only hide the
words if they're present in their
scriptures. Exactly. So, they are
present in the seventh century.
>> That's what they're saying.
>> The Quran agrees with us. We're more
>> I'm saying the words were present at
that time, but the Quran also says
people distorted and changed and
concealed them over generations. So,
preservation was in Where does it say
that? Where
>> where does it say that?
>> Where does it say generation?
>> Where does it say that? Yeah, I just I
>> dude, notice notice what you just did.
You just added words to the Quran.
>> You're not letting me speak. I can't
answer you if you're not letting the
scripture with your speech. You were
doing everything the Quran condemns you
for.
>> Jesus,
>> go ahead.
>> 513 says, "So for their breaking of the
covenant, we we cursed them and made
their hearts hard. They distort words
from their places, and I forgotten
portion."
>> How do they do that? How do they how do
they how do they do that? How do they
distort words from their places? Is that
textually or orally?
>> That that that is they say that distorts
words from their places means both
changing the text and it's meaning it's
>> No, no, no, no. My brother, come on. I
need you to be I need you to be serious
with me. In the verse when it says they
distort words from the right places, is
that textually? Does the verse say tell
you either or if it's textually or
verbally?
>> It's both, bro. It's both.
>> Does the verse say that?
>> No.
Okay, you're once once again he's
quoting something outside of the Quran
as
>> what's wrong with it. Could you please
like expand what's wrong with that?
>> Okay, let me let me I'll I'll explain it
to you. You went not us not you went to
surah 2:79. What does 279 say? Surah 279
says, "Woe to those who write the book
and then say this is from Allah." Okay,
we point out if you read that in
context, there's no way this is
referring to corruption of the text. So
what do you eventually say? You
eventually say, "Ah, but Ibn Abbas says
then we go to Abba show you it doesn't
say that." And now you keep saying all
of these things and so one you're you're
you're saying, "Ah, but he says that
this is happening over generations and
over generations of the Quran." We say,
"Where does it say that?" So you're
adding words to the Quran already with
your speech. You're distorting it with
your speech. But in addition to that,
you're saying, "Ah, yeah, I can't show
you where Allah is saying this, but I'll
go to a commentary, a later commentary,
and show you that." Which guess what? If
Allah were saying it, you could show us
where Allah is saying it. You can't show
us where Allah is saying it. So, you go
to a later Muslim who's saying it and
you say, "See, this is what Allah says."
That's what 279 condemns Jews for doing.
Going to something outside of the
scripture and treating it as if it's the
scripture. That's what you're doing
right now. You're doing exactly 100. If
you listed everything the Quran condemns
Jews and Christians for doing regarding
their scriptures, you've done it
already, which means you are condemned
as an unbeliever.
>> No, no, no. Let me first of all clarify
something so you guys know. The Quran
doesn't always spell out every detail in
one verse explained and we know it's the
most
>> because it's explained in detail. The
Quran claims to be explained in detail
and perfectly clear.
>> Uh where all over
>> Before we do that, guys, cuz I know
that's tempting. Before we do that,
let's finish 513 first though.
>> Okay.
>> So, so look, bro.
>> So, so David,
>> this is this is I taps man. Okay. And so
when he talks about they change words
from the right places, this is what he
says. Since their comprehension became
corrupt, their comprehension became
corrupt, they behaved treacherously with
Allah's ayat, altering his book from its
apparent meanings, which he sent down
and distorting its indications. They
attributed to Allah what he did not say,
and we seek refuge with Allah from such
behavior. So according to Ibath, is this
understood that they took the text and
messed up the text or that they
distorted the the apparent meanings?
Which one is it?
>> Okay. Could you please tell me where in
the it says that they haven't altered
it?
>> It doesn't. No, you show us.
>> This is on you.
>> No, no, he gave it. He gave it and was
like, "Okay, so this is a proof that I'm
not talking about.
>> I'm going to go ahead and move on to the
next person, man. I appreciate you."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Run away, you cry. I'm going
to run away.
>> You're running.
>> Like if anyone was running, it was him.
We he we go to the Quran. He's like,
"Well, now I got to go to Abbas. Oh, but
now I need to know if you speak Arabic."
Oh, but are you a are you a scholar of
Arabic? It's like or you have a degree
in Arabic. It's like just keep goal
shift posting here. But I was going to
say I was watching this whole thing. I
was like even if he is right in his
interpretation of like 513 279, he just
made the Quran hopelessly contradictory.
Because what does chapter 5 say in 568?
Oh people of the book, you have nothing
to stand on unless you observe the
Torah, the gospel in what has been
revealed to you from your Lord. 447,
it's confirming the book sent down is
confirming our scriptures. So even if he
is right, he just made the Quran
hopelessly contradictory because it says
according to him, these verses say the
cor that the our scriptures have been
corrupted. But then we can go to other
ays in the Quran where it says for us to
use our books that they're from Allah
that we they're confirmed. So again, you
take that route, Muslims, you make the
Quran contradict itself in multiple
places.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> All right. So we we went everywhere that
he that he wanted. We gave him
everything he wanted, did we not? Did we
not go and uh did we not go to um the
the verses? Did we not he then referred
to Ibn Abbas? Did we not go to Ibn Abbas
and show him that has the same opinion
we did? Did we not? We
>> and the English translation was exactly
what we said.
>> Exactly what you said. He agreed with
the Arabic and what you said. Yeah.
>> So, this is just this when you when you
show this that type of level of
dishonesty, we gave the boy a lot of
chances
>> and he just couldn't get get honest for
for for any any time frame. So, let me
read a couple super chats and then we
got
>> Hey yo yo yo yo one second. Yo, just
wanted to give him just wanted to give
him a couple uh just wanted to give him
those references because he did ask for
them. We didn't give them to them. uh
and he asked for references where the
Quran's claiming to be basically which
is basically every verse in the Quran
except for surah 3:7 when he got called
out on uh on some stuff uh but yeah so
what what do you say call him D uh yeah
so D uh since you're not familiar with
what the Quran says on this issue uh
surah 11:1 this is a book whose verses
have been made firm and free from
imperfection then they have been
expounded in detail right expounded in
detail 121 these are the verses of the
clear book 151 these are verses of the
book and of a Quran that makes things
clear. 2446 Certainly we have revealed
clear communications. 262 These are
verses of the book that makes things
clear. 271 These are verses of the
Quran, a book that makes things clear.
These are uh 282 these are verses of the
book that makes things clear. And 57:9
He it is who sends down clear
communications upon his servant that he
may bring you forth from utter darkness
into light. So the idea here is Allah is
saying over and over again his book is
clear and we look at what his clear book
says and all it ever does in any clear
passage is affirm the inspiration the
preservation and the authority of our
text. And when we ask you for one, I
mean one. Just give us one anywhere
verse in the Quran that says our books
have been corrupted, you guys go to
verses which can't possibly be claiming
that the Bible's been corrupted. And you
twist the meanings and then when we say
show us that from the text, you start
going to later commentaries by the by a
time when they were aware of when
they're aware of the fact that the Quran
contradicts the Bible. So you eventually
get to commentators who say that. But we
actually show you what your early
commentators say and they agree with us.
And so you're just in this disastrous
position where best case scenario
Allah's not saying it clearly. He's he's
the worst communicator in history. He
keeps saying, "Hey, I affirm the
inspiration preservation authority of
your books." But he really means
something else. In which case, guess
what? He's not clear. He's hopelessly
unclear. So why does he claim to be
clear? It's another dilemma.